parce qu'elle Perrineau bonjour Pascal
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
politologues professeur émérite à
l'Institut d'études politiques de Paris
Emmanuel anison bonjour Emmanuel merci
d'être là grand reporter à l'Obs et vous
suivez particulièrement ces mouvements
et on va en parler évidemment vous avez
suivi depuis le début de mouvement des
gilets jaunes on va parler tout ça
Audrey évidemment nous a rejoint et on
va parler dans ce club de la
mobilisation sociale nouvelle journée de
mobilisation aujourd'hui à l'appel des
syndicats et c'est la première depuis
l'adoption de la réforme alors qu'elle
peut être la réponse de la rue on verra
ça et puis même l'utilisation va-t-elle
changer de forme va-t-on vers une gilet
jaunisation de la contestation vous ne
direz ce que vous en pensez et on parle
de ces mobilisations tout de suite c'est
l'actualité dans nos régions
et l'actualité dans nos régions avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale et
des télévisions locales on va à Rennes
retrouver Stéphane Bernier bonjour
Stéphane merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
directeur de l'information de TV Rennes
et d'abord Stéphane on va revenir avec
vous sur la mobilisation des pêcheurs
hier à Rennes
on va on va revenir vers vous Stéphane
on a on a un petit problème de son on
revient vers vous vers vous très vite on
essaye de régler ça ah bah c'est bon
c'est réglé Stéphane et voilà on vous
entend voilà donc je vous disais Oriane
que cette
mection des pêcheurs était attendu avec
beaucoup d'inquiétudes même si on aime
la pêche même si on reconnaît un travail
exigeant avec des contraintes sur les
zones de pêche sur les salaires sur le
renouvellement de la flotte sur le
brexit mais dans toutes les mémoires
hier il y avait cette terrible journée
du 4 février
1994 car en marge de cette grande
manifestation là aussi nationale des
pêcheurs et bien le le Parlement de
Bretagne c'était embrasé entièrement
détruit il a fallu des années des années
des années de reconstruction donc hier
matin il y avait beaucoup de de peur et
ça a très vite dégénéré vous le voyez
sur ces images de la rédaction de de TVR
6 à 700 marins pêcheurs qui étaient
venus de toute la France crier leur
album on a eu beaucoup de scènes
d'embrasement des barricades beaucoup de
lancer de fusées et de fumigène on a
même vu dans le centre historique et
bien et diffuser se mettre pratiquement
sur les toitures c'est ce qui avait
conduit en 94 à la destruction du
Parlement de Bretagne et puis des scènes
de violence très violentes entre force
de l'ordre la CRS 8 et elle est
manifestant avec des scènes surréalistes
en train tracteur qui voulait défier un
lanceur d'eau saine vraiment très très
dur hier que vous voyez dans le centre
de la capitale bretonne grosse tension
dans cette manifestation nationale des
pêcheurs
façon plus générale
on en a du côté de Rennes et quelle
mobilisation peut-être attendu
aujourd'hui alors grosse mobilisation à
partir de 11 heures dans le centre de
Rennes ce matin et bien la rocade et
menacée avec des barrages filtrants à la
SNCF le train de 6h08 en gare de Rennes
à destination de Saint-Malo a été
entièrement bloqué également le centre
de dépôt principal des bus et bloqué
paralysé ce matin plus de 35 lignes de
bus ne vont pas circuler pour les deux
lignes A et B du métro René la pas de
souci des problèmes également au niveau
des poubelles les deux centres
d'enfouissement sont toujours paralysés
donc les poubelles débordent fortement
dans la capitale bretonne et puis au
niveau du tri postal c'est bloqué et
dans les écoles très écoles fermées 61
quand ils ne vont pas fonctionner et 33
temps d'écoles ne vont pas là aussi
fonctionner donc aujourd'hui grosse
manifestation et s'il faut donner une
forte de Fabrice lorestive le
responsable départemental de Force
Ouvrière et bien après la déclaration du
Président de la République on ne lâche
rien voilà la tonalité arène et en
Bretagne merci beaucoup merci Stéphane
benier directeur de l'information de TV
Rennes Emmanuel anison c'est la 9e
journée de mobilisation aujourd'hui mais
c'est la première depuis l'adoption de
la réforme au Parlement est-ce que ça
peut changer le profil des manifestants
et leur état d'esprit mais c'est toute
la question de cette semaine puisque
jusqu'ici on avait quand même dans les
manifestations en dehors je parle dans
un manifestation intercer syndicale je
parle de ce qu'on a vu depuis quelques
jours avec ce qu'on appelle s'échapper
sauvages il y avait il y avait quand
même beaucoup de militants c'était un
nœud de militants très à gauche
auquel s'agrégeait des gilets jaunes
qu'on retrouvait moi j'ai retrouvé en
pleine figure gilet jaune que je
connaissais et puis et puis quelques
quelques personnes en plus c'est vrai
que la question cette semaine ça va être
est-ce que est-ce que ce mouvement va
être rejoint par des personnes beaucoup
plus
type ces pêcheurs c'est à dire des
actifs des des jeunes par exemple dans
les j'ai quand même commencé à voir
aussi des jeunes de place de la Concorde
qui n'avaient même pas manifesté depuis
le début de l'année et qui disait ben on
vient parce que c'est 49-3 parce que là
c'est le vraiment le truc de trop en
fait dans face à un système politique
auquel on ne croit plus et c'est vrai
que là le bac va être passé il y a des
examens qui vont le passer toute la
question est de savoir est-ce que est-ce
que est-ce qu'il va y avoir une
mobilisation au-delà de ce cœur militant
en fait Pascal Perrineau on va rentrer
dans une autre forme de mobilisation
avec d'autres types de manifestants oui
mais c'est un enjeu tout à fait décisif
parce que si la mobilisation sociale
obéit j'allais dire à la logique qui a
précédé
l'usage de l'article 49 alinéa 3 au fond
le soutien d'opinion peut continuer
parce que il y avait une inter syndicale
unie ou relativement uni les
manifestations qui était grosso modo de
bonnes tenues là on s'aperçoit depuis
quatre ou cinq nuits en particulier dans
quelques grandes villes et qu'on vient
de ce qu'on vient de voir ce qui s'est
passé à Rennes en c'est pour ça que ça
change la violence et la violence
extrême parfois s'invite dans la
mobilisation sociale et on va voir
aujourd'hui est-ce que les syndicats ont
la capacité j'allais dire à maintenir
c'est le calme relatif qui existait dans
les mobilisations précédentes ou est-ce
que ça dégénère parce que à ce moment là
à ce moment là la grève d'opinion qui
fait la solidité de la mobilisation
sociale parce que des manifs à un
million etc en France on a déjà connu ça
dans le passé ça n'a jamais empêché
empêché la réforme des retraites de les
réformes des retraites du passé mais si
il faudrait regarder c'est le nombre de
grévistes voilà le nombre de grévistes
or là voilà on a des informations qui
montrent que le mouvement de grève n'est
pour l'instant pas un mouvement de grève
irrésistible donc il y a des indicateurs
qui sont des indicateurs
contradictoires mais surtout la grève
d'opinion est-ce qu'elle dure à ce
niveau là qui est un niveau de soutien
fort pour l'instant où est-ce qu'elle
commence à s'étioler et c'est le pari du
président de la République qui dit voilà
attendons attendons et puis on verra peu
à peu comme ça s'est passé toujours
depuis 93 sauf 95 et bien ça c'est
hurlera et voilà en septembre les
Français auront autre chose en tête
l'exécutif mis sur une usure sur un
pourrisson un pourrissement du mouvement
vous qui suivez ça de près Emmanuel
anison est-ce que vous sentez que ça
peut arriver cette usure du mouvement
pour moi c'est un c'est un pari
extrêmement dangereux parce que c'était
celui des gilets jaunes aussi et on est
plus on est à une époque où l'usure en
fait elle se traduit par la violence et
la radicalisation ouais c'est ça qui
m'inquiète beaucoup je trouve ça c'est
un pari à court terme vraiment
par deux on a vu avec les gilets jaunes
que quand il y a eu
l'idée que finalement ça ne servait à
rien qu'il n'était pas écouté pas le
pouvoir on est arrivé à une violence
extrême en décembre 2018 et d'ailleurs
c'est cette violence qui a fini par
faire bouger quelque chose en tout cas
c'est ce qu'on entend aujourd'hui les
manifestations c'est ce qui reste dans
dans la mémoire collective donc
si ce voilà si ce pourrissement amène à
ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui de plus en
plus depuis quelques jours
alors certes la l'option publique risque
de se désolidariser mais le fait que
l'opinion publique se désolidarise
n'amène pas la fin de la violence et on
l'a vu ça a duré sa durée deux ans quand
même les gilets jaunes et c'est une
journée aujourd'hui qui arrive au
lendemain de l'intervention d'Emmanuel
Macron mardi soir devant les
parlementaires de sa majorité sa
majorité le disait vouloir apaiser le
pays est-ce qu'hier il a réussi à
apaiser le pays non le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est qu'il n'a pas attendu
de
il a continué même à être dans l'analyse
qu'il faisait de la situation
critique vis-à-vis du mouvement et en
particulier du mouvement syndicat alors
il a utilisé un argument qui consistait
à dire en effet mais c'est syndicats
n'ont pas été porteurs d'une alternative
à aucun moment tout simplement parce que
les syndicats ne sont pas d'accord sur
ce que devrait être une réforme des
retraites
alors là il faut faire attention parce
que c'est à la fois un président qui
maintient le mouvement syndical à
longueur de gaffe en disant mais voilà
ils sont pas porteurs d'un intérêt
général qui pourrait être concurrent de
l'intérêt général que je représente moi
en tant que président de la République
mais il faut faire attention aussi parce
que dans l'opinion ça peut faire son
chemin les gens peuvent se dire oui
voilà on est dans une protestation qui
est une protestation de rejet mais il
faudra bien en sortir parce que les
Français ont l'impression que à la fois
sur le terrain social sur le terrain
politique on est un peu dans la nasse
comme les stratégies mises en place par
la police pour lutter contre les
manifestations et c'est assez
désagréable ce sentiment d'être dans la
nasse et il y aura la volonté la volonté
dans d'en sortir alors d'en sortir
comment je ne suis pas Madame solaire et
les Français commencent à sentir que
même s'il y avait par exemple une crise
une dissolution par exemple comme
l'avait fait de Gaulle après Mai 68 pour
prendre un témoin le peuple est-ce que
la majorité qui succèdent à la majorité
macroniste aurait plus de moyens qu'en a
la majorité macroniste je crois même que
ça serait le contraire je vais vous dire
ça serait encore pire on va revenir sur
les sur les syndicats évidemment parce
qu'elle Perrineau et Emmanuel Enzo dans
quelques instants et Emmanuel sur
l'intervention d'Emmanuel Macron hier
comment ça a pu être senti par les
manifestants est-ce que ça peut donner
l'impression d'une forme de déconnexion
voire de mépris c'est tout le problème
et oui c'est une intervention qui qui
dit écoutez j'avais raison vous vous
n'avez pas bien compris mais en fait
j'avais raison et on va continuer enfin
si je résume un peu c'est ça or tout
tout le malaise que l'on sent monté
depuis ces dernières années c'est c'est
cette déconnexion entre
une population et son regard très
défiant sur une élite politique on fasse
c'est vraiment le message de fond de
livrer par les gilets jaunes j'y reviens
et c'est celui que des vacances de
population aujourd'hui qui est sur le
terrain quand on l'écoute
ce 49-3 symbolique c'est le 49-3 c'est
celui de de quelqu'un qui ne sa même
manière n'a pas écouté des
manifestations pacifiques n'a pas écouté
des syndicats qui n'a pas reçu et n'a
pas écouté un parlement qui même si
c'est battu au sein du Parlement aurait
il aurait pu laisser aller au bout
jusqu'au bout du vote il ne l'a pas fait
il a contourné sur votre thé à plusieurs
reprises finalement donc c'est vrai que
jusqu'à ce discours qui qui reste un
discours
[Musique]
très très
presque face c'est une forme de de de
roi de d'un kiki je continue quoi qu'il
en coûte et c'est c'est un vrai problème
je pense d'image et de messages donnés
il y a une forme de déconnexion hier qui
est ressorti de cette interview selon
vous parce qu'elle perdant si vous
voulez il y a en effet le côté on a
connu au moment de la covid le quoiqu'il
en coûte financier là il y a un côté
quoi qu'il en coûte politiquement
le président est persuadé on le voit
bien c'est pas le seul mais il est
persuadé en effet qu'une réforme des
retraites et tout à fait nécessaire le
terme a été utilisé c'est nécessaire
c'est de l'ordre de la nécessité
bon il était d'ailleurs au départ pour
une réforme d'un type tout à fait
différente celle qui menait qui était la
réforme à point qui à mon avis
d'ailleurs est une réforme beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus ambitieuse et de longue
durée parce que là c'est une réforme
mais dans trois ans on sera obligé de
recommencer une autre réforme donc en
effet il maintient le cap mais m'inter
le cap c'est peut-être très bien mais
encore faut-il pour un président de la
République restait en lien avec
l'opinion et là hier
on avait l'impression d'un président qui
avait écouté de manière extrêmement
sélective le message qui venait d'en bas
et qui parlait de l'après il était déjà
complètement dans l'après les trois
grands dossiers qu'il a ouvert dans son
intervention d'hier c'est pour l'après
c'est-à-dire pour lui l'affaire est plié
mais attention la mobilisation sociale
si elle perdure peut provoquer des
évolutions de type différence
souvenons-nous à la fin du quinquennat
de Jacques Chirac Jacques Chirac disait
en effet on avait l'impression que
c'était plié là aussi le CPE contrat
premier embauche était voté puis peu à
peu ben voilà le rapport de force a
évolué et ce contrat a été
et c'est sûr sur quoi Miss d'ailleurs
les syndicats et les manifestants
Emmanuel ils font très souvent
références à CEPE qui était retiré et
l'idée c'est on continuera jusqu'à ce
que la loi soit retirée sachant qu'on
est plus mm époque quand on a vraiment
franchi les degrés de violence de part
et d'autre à un manifestant et force de
l'ordre et
ben je je pense qu'entre temps le risque
le risque de de qu'on a connu enfin
telle que Malikou c'est kiné est un vrai
risque dans la rue enfin là comment
aller pour les avoir suivi là ces
derniers jours
les courses poursuites dans les petites
rues laisse libre cours à tout et
n'importe quoi et justement Emmanuel
Macron on va l'écouter il s'est adressé
assez manifestants violents hier on
écoute ce qu'il a dit
on ne peut accepter
ni les faction ni les factions
ceci il faut les écouter faut écouter
leurs colères et y répondre voilà il
fait la différence entre les
manifestants classiques dans le
mouvement syndical et les manifestants
violents on peut accepter ni les
factions ni les factieux à qui ne
s'adresse précisément quand tu prononces
cette phrase parce qu'elle fait non
alors il s'adresse bien sûr à ces
éléments incontrôlés des étangs jadis et
factieux et les factions d'ailleurs
c'est un ton incroyablement gaulien
cette terminologie que n'aurait pas
renié le fondateur de la Cinquième
République mais à l'époque les factions
voyaient bien ce que c'était les
factions voyaient bien ce que c'était là
c'est beaucoup plus indécis il y a en
effet cette espèce de gilets jaunisation
qui transforme parfois des citoyens
relativement paisibles en personne qui
vont oui se mettre à agresser les
policiers acheter éventuellement des
bouteilles des on a vu ça déjà au moment
du mouvement des gilets jaunes et cette
espèce de brutalisation des certains de
la Société des rapports entre la
population et la police la police et la
population c'est de mauvais augure parce
qu'on a une démocratie représentative
qui est fragile touché par l'abstention
on est à peine élu on est déjà contesté
et donc il faut retrouver mais ça n'est
pas simple un lien entre le pouvoir
politique et cette opinion qui vit
essentiellement maintenant sur le mode
de la colère
indignez-vous disait et celle là
maintenant on pourrait dire mettez-vous
en colère
il y a effectivement ce passage de du
citoyen dit pacifique au clairement ça
on a vraiment les gilets jaunes ça a été
en quelques semaines on avait des gens
complètement ouvriers et de venir
vraiment violent et dont certains
d'ailleurs ont rejoint les Black Blocs
complètement il y a une fusion aussi de
ces militants d'extrême gauche violents
avec
gilets jaunes qui étaient pas du tout
d'extrême gauche pas du tout politisés
et qui ont fini par adopter toutes ces
méthodes et c'est ce qu'on retrouve
aujourd'hui sur le terrain effectivement
quand on se promenait dans les
manifestations pacifiques ces dernières
semaines moi je posais systématiquement
la question mais interlocuteurs en
disant et la violence et même de la part
de d'adultes de de personnes de profun
université
j'entendais ce discours de dire bon bah
moi non mais au fond peut-être qu'elle
va être nécessaire enfin on est on est
il y a cette petite musique là et face à
ça quand on dit on ne sait pas quoi
faire mais il y a une demande absolument
mais fondamentale aujourd'hui de
changement de système politique je parle
pas de Sixième République ça je pense
simplement d'une de participation les
citoyens aujourd'hui estimes qui doivent
plus participer
au fonctionnement de la politique la
démocratie participative qui d'ailleurs
avait été une des promesses de
d'Emmanuel Macron en 2017 il avait dit
qu'il rajouterait de la participation à
sa démocratie ce qui est clairement n'a
pas été le cas sur la violence c'est
vrai qu'on l'a entendu dans les
reportages des professeurs des des
personnes en famille qui manifestaient
qui disaient on est des millions dans la
rue on n'est pas entendu peut-être qu'il
faut en venir à une certaine force de
violence et c'est vrai que
il y a pas d'issue il voyait pas d'issue
différentes sur ce sujet et est-ce que
ce ressenti chez les manifestants c'est
aussi une mauvaise nouvelle pour les
syndicats jusqu'à maintenant les
manifestations syndicales se sont
toujours bien passées est-ce que c'est
une mauvaise nouvelle cette
radicalisation est-ce que ça pourrait
dégénérer oui les syndicats on le voit
quand on écoute les leaders syndicaux et
particulièrement Laurent Berger personne
n'a envie que la violence s'invite au
cœur des grandes manifestations comme
celles qui auront lieu cet après-midi
mais il faut bien voir que si vous
voulez on est en France on n'est pas en
Allemagne on n'est pas en
Grande-Bretagne on n'est pas en Suède
loin de là et qu'il y a en France ce
qu'un historien François Furet jadis
s'appelait la culture révolutionnaire si
vous les parties communistes et presque
morts mais la culture fonctionnaires
dont il était porteur à une certaine
époque reste une réalité
et c'est ce sont des gens qui ont
l'impression qu'au bout de leur action
éventuellement violente il y a un
changement radical des règles du jeu
politique économique et sociales le
mythe de la barricade j'ai goûté tout à
l'heure attentivement leur portage sur
Rennes bah voilà certains pêcheurs ou
manifestants qui accompagnaient les
pêcheurs ont commencé à ériger les
barricades et en France ça émet une
partie de la population vous passeriez
la frontière en Allemagne ça ne me
personne
c'est vrai qu'on entendait aussi
régulièrement dans les rangs de Cell
alors papa pas de pas des manifestations
pacifiques mais là depuis quelques jours
ces images de tête décapités de enfin
voilà on est on est dans le pays de la
Révolution et d'ailleurs une jeune fille
de qui avait qui avait 18 19 ans là en
première année de droit qui qui me
disait en voyant les images on a pensé à
la Révolution alors on est venu
voilà donc c'est c'est il y a cette
tradition clairement on parlait des
syndicats Audrey comment les syndicats
ont réagi à l'interview du chef de
l'État hier pas très bien c'est un
euphémisme le président a pourtant
affirmé hier qui voulait renouer le
dialogue il les a appelés à revenir à la
table des négociations après la
manifestation d'aujourd'hui pour se
pencher sur un texte sur les conditions
de travail notamment mais pas sûr que
les syndicats aient entendu cette partie
parce que quelques minutes plus tôt le
chef de l'État leur a adressé un tacle
assez musclé il a regretté je cite
qu'aucune force syndicale n'est proposée
de compromis sur la réforme des
retraites je vous laisse imaginer la
réaction des principaux concernés quand
on sait qu'il y a eu de nombreuses
consultations avec Elisabeth borne à
l'automne et qu'il y a quelques semaines
ils ont demandé à plusieurs reprises
d'être reçus par le chef de l'État sans
succès écouter une première réaction
celle de Philippe Martinez
je vais le dire trivialement cette
interview c'est du foutage de gueule et
c'est du mépris encore plus fort
vis-à-vis des millions de personnes qui
manifestent ils considère qu'il y a pas
eu de proposition alternative
alors que la CGT comme je suppose les
autres organisations syndicales on fait
des propositions alternatives mais il ne
considère que les propositions
alternatives ne sont valables que si on
est d'accord avec lui
le chef de l'État est parvenu en tout
cas à garder les syndicats unis contre
lui François omery le patron de la
CFE-CGC le syndicat des cadres et des
encadrants a estimé qu'Emmanuel Macron
poursuivait sa case sociale mais il y en
a un qui a vu particulièrement rouge
hier c'est Laurent Berger le secrétaire
général de la CFDT le syndicat
réformiste nommément cités dans
l'interview Emmanuel Macron estime qu'il
refuse l'allongement de l'âge de départ
en retraite en raison de conflits
internes dans son syndicat écouter la
réaction de Laurent Berger le président
de la République aujourd'hui c'était
c'est factuellement faux
et s'est déplacé c'est déplacé de
pointer à responsable syndicale dans une
intervention comme ça je n'ai pas
compris c'est pas le truc principal de
ce qui s'est dit aujourd'hui c'est à
dire l'absence de réponse pour les
salariés et pour les gens qui
manifestent qui sont en désaccord mais
on a proposé un compromis au sens où on
a proposé une autre réforme qui était
d'ailleurs la réforme du président de la
République en 2017 et en 2019 il y a
deux choses qu'on peut changer
c'est ce que disait le président de la
République à l'époque en 2019 on peut
pas repousser l'âge légal tant qu'on est
avec ce taux ce taux d'emploi les
seniors aussi faible l'autre chose qu'un
pas changé c'est comment vous voulez
qu'on travaille quand vous êtes une
aide-soignante quand vous êtes un
égoutier jusqu'à 60 ans Alors vous êtes
déjà pas en possibilité vraiment de le
faire physiquement jusqu'à 62 ans
vous le voyez Oriane les syndicats sont
pas prêts de revenir à la table des
négociations effectivement il a fait une
erreur hier le chef de l'État avec les
syndicats Emmanuel anison mais il a fini
erreur depuis le début avec les
syndicats il y a un énorme problème de
dialogue de de d'ouverture surtout avec
un Laurent Berger donc on sait très bien
qu'il y avait il y avait vraiment une
porte possible et que c'est quand même
un syndicat qui part par essence et qui
est un syndicat de conciliation de
discussion de négociation mais il y a
une énorme il y a énormément erreur de
timing depuis le début aussi enfin posé
cette retraite en ce moment c'était déjà
extrêmement explosif et tout dans cette
attitude qui est une attitude de non
écoute de non dialogue
a contribué à faire de ce syndicat un
vrai bloc par ailleurs les syndicats on
sait ont été dépassés par leurs bases
dernières années et c'est la hantise de
ces syndicats aujourd'hui de dépassé par
leurs bases qui qui sans six en fait
grosso modo c'est les syndicats
négocient trop les bases s'organisent
entre elles c'est et c'est une vraie
d'ailleurs on est on est en un moment à
mon avis qui va être très compliqué
c'est à dire que j'ai fait un reportage
là au Havre à la raffinerie de Normandie
les les ceux qui bloque et me disaient
en 2016 en a reculé quand on fait partie
arrêter on arrêtait cette fois-ci on
arrêtera plus
ça veut dire qu'il y a un risque
effectivement que leader syndicaux ne
tienne plus leur base oui oui bien sûr
parce que d'abord les syndicats si vous
voulez il faut tout même revenir à
quelque chose de réel quand vous
comparez les syndicats en France par
rapport à ce qui se passe en Europe les
syndicats sont faibles en France il faut
pas croire 8% des salariés français sont
syndiqués donc l'encadrement voilà des
salariés en colère ça n'est pas une
masse affaire mais je crois que derrière
il y a un problème plus large plus
fondamental qui explique d'ailleurs un
peu le comportement du président de la
République c'est que ce président de la
République est hostile au fond aux corps
intermédiaires traditionnels on voit ces
rapports très difficiles avec les élus
locaux on voit ces rapports très
difficiles en effet avec les partis
traditionnels et avec les syndicats
traditionnels alors très bien on peut
avoir ce type de position quand on est
porteur d'une solution alternative et
qu'on se dit voilà on va créer de
nouveaux corps intermédiaires mais il
faut bien reconnaître que depuis 2017 ça
a été un échec regardons par exemple
voilà les marcheurs devenus Renaissance
il n'a pas réussi à créer de nouveaux
élus locaux macronistes véritablement il
n'a pas réussi à créer par exemple un
parti macroniste or on ne peut pas
continuer en France avec ce dialogue qui
n'en est pas un c'est un immense
malentendu entre un président censé
avoir tous les pouvoirs et qui ne les a
pas d'ailleurs et des citoyens à la base
atomisés et en colère sans aucun corps
intermédiaire pour faire le lien c'est
délétère et cette dangereux c'est la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes et
Emmanuel Macron il a parlé de la
question du travail est-ce que Emmanuel
anison la question du travail c'était
pas ce qui était au cœur des
revendications des gilets jaunes est-ce
qu'il y avait pas chez eux le sentiment
de vivre dans un pays où le travail
payait mal et est-ce que cette le fait
de focaliser prochainement sur la
question du travail ça peut être une
réponse ça peut être une sortie du
conflit
alors il y a la question du travail oui
mais au-delà de cette question du
rapport au travail il y a question du
fonctionnement de la société beaucoup
plus largement et c'est pour ça que
c'est la réponse elle est compliquée à
amenée c'est-à-dire qu'on n'est pas que
dans une revendication de travail qui
paye mal on a bien vu les gilets jaunes
ça a commencé par un problème économique
c'était le prix de du pétrole à la pompe
et puis on est arrivé effectivement on a
parlé de la relation de travail qui paye
pas suffisamment pour remplir son frigo
mais très vite on est arrivé à des des
discussions et beaucoup beaucoup très
c'était très très dense sur les
ronds-points et dans des salles de
discussion sur le rapport à la
démocratie comment fonctionne une
démocratie on a beaucoup dans toutes les
pancartes on voyait le RIC référendum
d'initiative citoyenne l'idée que le
qu'aujourd'hui le citoyen devait devait
se réapproprier en fait les outils
politiques il y avait une vraie demande
et c'est quelque chose qu'on ressent
aussi aujourd'hui on ressent ça chez les
jeunes et enfin faut pas oublier tout ça
aboutit à quoi à une abstention à un
vote extrême et c'est ce vers quoi on va
encore plus quand on traverse la crise
comme celle-ci donc même dans le calcul
à court terme de pourrissement de de oui
mais à long terme on est sur des en fait
des des traumatismes qui qui qui les a
après les autres amènent à se
désinfections vis-à-vis du politique et
c'est ça qui est dramatique est-ce que
c'est pas finalement une forme de
paradoxe avec des manifestants qui
demandent à participer à être plus actif
et en même temps une abstention record
oui la question démocratique est
certainement au cœur d'un malaise
gigantesque bien antérieur d'ailleurs au
président Macron c'est pas Macron en
tant que président de la République qui
a créé tous ces problèmes la question
démocratique on la connaît en France
depuis 20 ans il y a un doute de plus en
plus par rapport aux mécanismes
classiques de la démocratie
représentative dont le moment fort et
l'élection donc il faut inventer autre
chose Dominique Rousseau le
constitutionnaliste dit il faut
démocratiser la démocratie et je crois
que là
une vraie question posez la question
c'est simple y apporter une réponse
c'est très compliqué alors il y a la
démocratie participative alors le
président l'avait annoncé ici et c'est
avec tous ces
consultations
d'un échantillon de français tirés au
hasard en ce moment par exemple il y a
un travail très intéressant mené sur la
fin de vie mais vraiment extrêmement
intéressant j'avais été regardé ça de
près c'est tout à fait passionnant de
travail
qui est issu de cet instant de
démocratie
participative et puis il y a la
démocratie directe l'appel au peuple par
le biais du référendum mais voyez c'est
très bien de dire voilà il y a ça mais
ensuite il faut articuler ces
différentes démocraties parce que les
démocrates la démocratie participative
c'est formidable moi j'avais suivi le
grand débat national après la crise des
gilets jaunes c'est formidable mais ça
reste toujours une démocratie de
minorité de fortes minorités le grand
national ça a été environ 2 millions de
participants là il y a au maximum un
million et demi de participants aux
manifestations la démocratie
manifestante dans la rue mais à la fin
des fins la légitimité c'est ben voilà
ce sont les élus et donc il faut
vraiment penser de manière concrète
comment la démocratie participative
nourrit la démocratie représentative
est-ce que ça veut dire parce que la
réponse très rapide au gilet jaune ça
avait été ce fameux grand débat national
indonés parce qu'aujourd'hui on peut
avoir un grand débat national sur la
question du travail
le problème c'est que c'est un peu tard
c'est ça c'est que oui il aurait fallu
l'engager ce débat mais il y a deux mois
là là on est on est à un moment où tout
l'attention c'est tellement tellement
cristallisé que que je
j'ai l'impression que ça serait trop
tard la réponse du coup parce qu'il y
avait eu le grand débat il y avait eu
assez rapidement des mesures financières
à engager par le chef de l'État après le
début du mouvement aujourd'hui quelle
peut être la réponse qu'elle peut être
la sortie mais pardon à même le grand
débat n'avait pas été aperçu comme comme
une vraie démarche pratique c'était
plutôt perçu comme un moyen d'enterrer
le mouvement de calmer artificiellement
les contestations mais au fond qu'en
est-il sorti alors oui une convention
citoyenne enfin très très à la marge la
réalité c'est qu'on voit bien le mode de
de de aujourd'hui opératoire de
d'Emmanuel Macron n'a pas changé c'est
même ça qui est étonnant à quel point
finalement les leçons n'ont pas été
tirés de tout ce qu'il dit depuis 2017
il a il a connu la plus grosse crise
sociale depuis 1968 en 2018 avec les
gilets jaunes et on a l'impression que
c'est le son n'ont pas donc aujourd'hui
dire après coup au moment où il y a tout
le monde dans la rue où c'est le feu et
où vraiment on se dit que jusqu'où cela
va-t-il basculer et on se dit maintenant
on va engager un grand débat sur le
travail mais c'est presque absurde un
dernier mot parce que finalement
aujourd'hui celui qui cristallise la
colère c'est le chef de l'État je pense
que sa politique
oui en partie il y a un style qui
contribue à fasciner certains mais on
exaspéré bien d'autres donc oui il y a
de l'anti macronisme mais attendez il y
avait de l'anti-sarkozyme voilà bon
Macron n'est pas exceptionnel à cet
égard mais il y a certainement une
capacité de cet homme j'allais dire à
suscité à la fois de la part de ce qu'il
soutiennent un sentiment d'admiration et
de remise de soi au président de la
République et de l'autre côté voilà on
se met à couper les têtes à brûler les
effigies du président et au sort on ne
peut pas s'en réjouir non plus
en 2018 ce que je trouve inquiétant
c'est que cette aujourd'hui il y a une
violence envers tous les élus politiques
si vous regardez les permanences qui
sont vandalisés donc il y a même eu je
trouve un degré supplémentaire qui a été
franchi dans la haine du politique plus
largement merci beaucoup merci Emmanuel
anison merci Pascal pour cette analyse
du mouvement c'était passionnant
enrichissant merci d'avoir été avec nous
la Une de l'Obs cette semaine qui sort
aujourd'hui c'est Emmanuel Macron la
République enlisée on la voit Emmanuel
Macron en photo merci Emmanuel anison
merci Pascal merci Audrey on se retrouve
demain
[Musique]